[Music]
the final chapter of ursula kayla
green's third earth-sea novel the
farthest shore
includes a
vivid description of a homecoming
riding on a dragon's back in fact the
oldest dragon in existence coalescing
but it begins
with ged and aaron or lebon and as his
his true name and having emerged
from the dry land lebanon took them
over the mountains of pain and they
emerge onto the beach both are totally
exhausted lebanon both physically and
spiritually ged as well
and get his also exhausted his entire
power
as a mage he at one point once he wakes
up
and there's a question should he take
his staff he says i'm not a mage anymore
i
poured out all the power
that i had to close up this rift between
the two different realms
and so what we find at the beginning of
this chapter is rn or lebanon
really struggling and trying to tend to
to ged who is totally
unresponsive
there's a description very cold very
heavy dead seem to him he'd borne him
over the boundary from death into life
but maybe in vain he put his ear to
get's breast but could not steal the
shaking in his own limbs and the
chattering of his teeth to listen for
the heartbeat he goes to a stream and
fills up water bottles
water skins rather and there
he sees the iron black dragon by the
spring
and you know up until this point
it's been largely
ged and lebanon working with the dragons
or at least some of the dragons to
counteract this threat but he has no
idea what to expect at this time
so here's the description
as at last he sat up and as he did so he
saw on the far side of the stream
immense a dragon its head the color of
iron stained as with red rust at nostril
and eye socket and jowl hung facing
almost over him the talons sank deep
into the soft wet sand on the edge of
the stream the folded wings were partly
visible like sails but the length of the
dark body was lost in the fog it did not
move it might have been crouching there
for hours
or for years or centuries it was carving
of iron shaped from rock but the eyes
the eyes he dared not look into the eyes
like oil coiling on water like yellow
smoke behind glass the opaque profound
yellow eyes watched aaron there was
nothing he could do he so he stood up if
the dragon would kill him it would and
if it did not he would try to help get
if there was any help for him
he says the dragon did nothing it
crouched unmoving and watched so
he goes and fills the water skins up
tries to get ged to drink and he's
tending to him
when the dragon comes over
and this is just the next page
this is a little bit later on in the day
there was a noise as of metal rubbing
against metal the greeting whisper of
crossed swords the iron-colored dragon
had risen on its crooked legs it moved
and crossed the riverlet with a soft
hissing sound as it dragged its long
body through the sand
aaron saw the wrinkles at the shoulder
joints the male of the flanks scored and
scarred like the armor of aerith akba
and the long teeth yellowed and blunt in
all this and its sure ponderous
movements and in a deep and frightening
calmness that it had he saw the sign of
age
of great age of years beyond remembering
so aaron puts two and two together and
he doesn't speak the old speech that the
dragons speak and the mages learn
and he says uh in hardik the language of
earth see art thou colesson are you
the
oldest of dragons at this point the
dragon doesn't talk to him
he says but it seemed to smile
then lowering its huge head and sticking
out its neck it looked down at ged and
spoke his name its voice was huge and
soft and smelled like a blacksmith's
forge
three times it calls ged's name on the
third time get awakens
and he
recognizes him kalesin he said and then
he speaks to him in the old speech
and the dragon um moves over
the dragon puts out a great male foot
almost touching him the talons of that
foot were four with a spur behind as a
coxfoot has but these are spurs of steel
long as scythe blades so you know long
like like this
giant
nails and the dragon says to him a word
sobrious like a january wind through
frozen weeds and aaron misinterprets he
says
leave get alone he's had enough he's
gone through a lot don't bother him let
him rest and get wakes up and says oh no
there's something else going on here the
dragon is telling you
mount up
get get up here i'm putting my foot out
so you can climb up on that and that's
what they do
and
aaron's thoughts are this is all folly
but there was the great talent foot set
like a step in front of him and above it
the crook of the elbow joint and above
it the jutting shoulder and the
musculature of the wing where it sprang
from the shoulder blade four steps a
stairway
and there in front of the wings and the
first great iron thorn of the spine
armor in the hollow of the neck there
was a place for a man to sit astride or
two men if they were mad and past hope
and given up to folly
and that is indeed where they are
they are at the end of the world at
celador
the
boat look far as as leguin remarks is on
a different coast of celador
totally unprovisioned there is
no way
to go anywhere other than with this
dragon and so it is folly but it it is
what it is
and um
aaron helps ged to mount up
and
collison turned and looked at them side
long the ancient laughter was in its eye
whether coliseum was male or female
there was no telling what colesen
thought there was no knowing
and you know they they begin to to fly
over
salador
uh to the east
and then we get this account right of a
few islands seeing the dragon a great
dragon flying over them some of them
saying wow look at this and some of them
say oh no this is terrible but the
dragon keeps on going it doesn't bother
with any of them until it comes to the
one place
where apparently
no dragons can go but in reality this
dragon can go the island of rock
and
it lands
what happens then never in the memory of
man scarcely in the memory of legend had
any dragon braved the walls visible and
invisible to the well-defended isle this
one did not hesitate but flew on
ponderous wings and heavily over the
western shore of rock above the villages
and fields to the green hill that rises
over twill town
there at last it stopped slowly to the
earth raised its red wings and folded
them and crouched on the summit of rock
knoll
the we find that the uh council has been
restored
the patterner comes from his grove the
changer had returned two nights before
in the shape of a great sea osprey
and um the summoner gaunt and frail only
one day risen from his bed had come and
beside him stood the doorkeeper and the
other masters of the isle of the wise
were there
what did they see
now it's kind of told through their eyes
they saw the writers dismount one aiding
the other
they saw them look about with a look of
strange contentness grimness and wonder
ged speaks to the dragon
and it briefly answers him
and
those who understood heard the dragon
say i have brought the young king to his
kingdom and the old man to his home
notice what he's saying there ged is the
old man get as the archmage but now he's
no longer a mage at all so how can he be
the archmage he is only an old man
despite being a hero of legends
aaron who came just as a young man
full of promise perhaps but you know
nobody knowing exactly what he would be
he is now the king
and it's a dragon
saying this
in the hearing of the masters of broke
so you know that's not nobody saying it
right that's not him asserting it
ged says
a little farther yet coalescing i have
not gone
where i must go
then he turns to aaron
and in the sight of them all ged knelt
to him down on both knees and bowed his
great head saying when you come to your
throne in havre my lord and dear
companion
rule long and well so this is a passing
on
of something there is a you know some
conjecture that maybe
a king was needed and not an archmage
that power would pass rulership would
pass guidance would pass from one to the
other ged is going to go back onto his
childhood home
in the island of gantt
so he looked again at the masters and
the young wizards and the boys in the
townfolk gathered on the slopes
and at the foot of the knoll his face
was quiet and in his eyes was something
like the laughter in the eyes of colesen
turning from the mall he mounted up
again by the dragon's foot and shoulder
and took his seat rainless between the
great peaks of the wings on the neck of
the dragon
collecting the eldest spraying into the
air
and it circled the hill once and flew
off north and eastward towards that
quarter of earth sea where stands the
mountain isle of gant the doorkeeper has
the last word saying he has done with
doing he goes home
that's how we know that it's going to be
gant that he's going to
and this is the end of the story this is
the end of the trilogy
with the
coming of the new young king
and
the end of the career
of this great wizard get
you